the Euro welcome the agreement that was
achieved on the policy package that you
now pave the way for a successful
completion of the first review of the
ESM program corps in that package is of
course the pension reform personal
income tax reform and additional fiscal
parametric measures some of which have
already been legislated last night in
Greek parliament what we did on the
contingency mechanism is basically take
the last proposal from the Greek
government and enforce it in our
discussions today to make sure that
there is the option of permanent
structural measures agreed with the
institutions including revenue measures
which could become effective in the year
thereafter so that's an addition and
amendment to the Greek proposal on adept
we had a first round of discussion of
course any measures will be conditional
upon full implementation of the measures
agreed in the program and will be
considered later on there was no
decisions today deal or not hold when I
arrived today I said that we needed an
agreement on Greece and today thanks to
a positive and constructive discussion I
believe we've made important progress
towards such an agreement on that basis
i'm quite confident that we will be able
to take positive decisions at our next
meeting on the twenty-fourth of may I
think today really would say work in
progress but working good progress